(bright music)
- So today we're gonna
try a new form of yoga.
I don't know what it is.
- I've done yoga a few times before.
- I can't be still, I can't be calm.
That's one of the main reasons
why I've never tried yoga.
- Yoga is a really great
outlet for me to decompress.
I'm excited to try it.
Let's do it.
- So today we're gonna
surprise a group of yogis
with baby goats for
what we call goat yoga.
- Yoga, we kind of just integrate the mind
with the body, with the breath.
We did a few different
positions in the beginning
that were just really
basic and really simple.
- There wasn't really anything
that I haven't done before.
- Nothing happened for a while,
and so I just got into it.
- I felt relaxed. I felt good.
- [Galeit Sehayek) When you're
ready, just close your eyes
Another really big thing in yoga is
that we're in a constant
state of change, right?
There's good things happening,
bad things happening.
(laughter)
Yup, that's gonna happen a lot! (laughs)
It was everything I dreamed of.
Goat yoga is nothing different
than taking your dog for a walk.
You're bonding with that animal,
and you're getting exercise.
It's my form of the new
animal-assisted therapy.
It just makes people forget all
the hard things they're going through.
- When we would go down, they
would jump on your backs.
- I felt my muscles just relaxing
with each step that they took.
- Baby goats are really
just playful animals
and they're not afraid
to connect with you.
(cheerful music)
- Yoga is really good for
your mental health anyways,
but adding an animal to the mix
exponentially increases that.
- Although I couldn't really focus
on the yoga part because
the goats were just so cute,
it works that way, too,
because the whole point
of yoga is just to relax your mind
and be happy about your surroundings,
which exactly was what I was feeling.
- Animals in general, they
make me feel at peace,
like when I pet my dog, and
just playing with those goats
made me feel so good, I completely forgot
about the outside world.
- There should be more types of exercise
incorporating animals into them
because they make us happy.
They're pure and genuine.
- A lady who had breast cancer -
just the fact that that goat could
make her happy and after all she's been
through, I really think there's
just a healing quality about
that human-animal bond.